they told us
you will
go to wonder
tomorrow
in this detention center near heathrow
25 year old sahir not his real name says
he can't eat or sleep he fled iraq two
months ago crossed europe in a lorry
then the channel in a boat less than a
month here and he now faces deportation
to rwanda
where you live
era why you want to claim asylum and i
just say my life in danger and they see
that your case is refused
and they give us a ticket removal to
direction to rwanda
at the court of appeal in london today a
last-ditch legal challenge to stop
tomorrow's flight failed
for the reasons you have given
this appeal is dismissed
and when a second action also failed in
the high court protesters outside were
dismayed they are not looking at what
exactly is in that country they are
looking at
the fact that britain is getting an
opportunity to dispose of asylum seekers
but they are not sick the life they're
putting in their job
at another detention center brook house
in gatwick syed not his real name and
his friend have managed to postpone
their deportations to rwanda both are
from afghanistan
saeed paid traffickers 1 900 pounds to
cross the channel and says he would
rather die than be sent to rwanda
now
well there's not much to do here at
brookhouse detention center other than
watch planes barreling down the runway
on the other side of the road here at
gatwick airport not knowing whether they
soon will be on one heading towards
rwanda not because they don't have the
right to claim asylum here but because
of the way they came here by boat and
the government's belief that this policy
will deter others from doing the same
but more than 600 people crossed the
channel in small boats in the first week
of this month and more than 100 arrived
in the last 24 hours after individual
legal challenges it's thought just a
handful will leave on this first flight
to rwanda
jason farrell sky news